an apple weighs about 1 Newton the world
record for jet engine thrust is five
hundred and seventy thousand Newtons and
the Saturn 5 rocket that launched people
to the moon had a thrust of 33 million
three hundred and sixty thousand Newtons
but how can we measure forces this big
accurately well we need to ask this guy
hi my name's Rick ciphers I'm a physical
scientist in the massive force group
sure okay Rick manages a dead weight
machine that can apply four million four
hundred forty eight thousand 222 Newtons
why is such a strange number because
that's exactly equal to 1 million pounds
of force there are twenty fifty fifty
thousand pound increments in this
machine 20 times 50 equals 1 million
pounds joomla tively that's 4.45 mega
Newton elsewhere in the world are there
larger masses that people have
calibrated I asked that question to
every visitor we get and I've not gotten
one responses says yeah I know we're
bigger stuff is calibrated so if I
really want to go out on a limb and brag
I'll say these are the largest mass
objects ever calibrated anywhere the
machine works like this
below ground are the 20 carefully
calibrated masses their weight is used
to calibrate for sensors also called
force transducers in the lab upstairs
this is a 1 million pound capacity for
0.45 mega Newton and this is 3.3 mega
news 3 million pounds force this is the
biggest percentage of its type in the
world and obviously one of a kind one of
these will be placed on a compression
head right here then a hydraulic ram in
the Attic starts to raise the green
lifting frame
and once the force transducer contacts
the red loading frame well then it
starts lifting the weights downstairs
and as the lifting frame continues to
rise more and more of the 50,000 pound
weights become suspended by the force
sensor and since the weights create an
accurately known force the readouts from
the force transducer can be precisely
calibrated these devices are then sent
out into the field well literally
literally there's a test and it's set up
with one of these gizmos when a force
transducers embedded in the test stands
somewhere
our journey to Mars and so the rocket is
fired up perhaps ramped up ramp down and
those forces are monitored you know the
old bill movie hero I go to 104 percent
of power well how do they know it's 104
percent of power because somebody's
measured it somewhere when it comes to
minimizing uncertainty these guys aren't
messing around this piece right here is
approximately 50,000 36.2 7 pounds of
mass approximately approximately yeah
think about that for a moment each of
these pieces has a mass equivalent to 10
minivans and their exact value is known
within several American Nicholas just a
few American nickels yeah where the
difference yeah
that tiny uncertainty is measured with
respect to the very definition of the
kilogram using k20 that's the United
States fundamental mass standard this is
done by comparing combinations of known
weights starting with K 20 with larger
unknown weights gradually working up to
larger and larger masses for example
here a single 5 kilogram mass is
compared to two twos and a one at some
point in this process they convert and
start working in pounds going from
50-pound masses to 500 pounds and then
2,500 pounds and then using a scale in
the floor to reach 10,000 pounds and
then 20,000 and finally 30,000 pounds
combinations of these huge weights are
then used to calibrate the 50,000 pound
masses which form the weight stack and
we have to have that because what we
sell is the vertical force vector that's
generated by these weights hanging in a
gravitational field we sell that with an
uncertainty attached to it of point zero
zero zero five percent five parts per
million so that means at full 1 million
pounds of applied force we guarantee
that to be accurate if you will within 5
pounds not only does that mean the
masses have to be accurately calibrated
it also means the gravitational
acceleration at this location has to be
taken into account it's actually
slightly less than Earth's standard
gravity so an additional 600 pounds are
required plus the buoyant force must be
counteracted since these masses displace
a hundred and twenty-five pounds of
a further 125 pounds must be added to
reach a million pounds of force what
what strikes me is kind of amazing is
that like this machine needs to exist in
a way like yeah yeah what when I when I
would have thought about it like how
would Boeing measure its forces I would
have thought okay they just you know
calibrate a device that works you know
up to X but then they can you know yes
generalize well generalize you know what
I mean yes there's an axiom that says
one physical test is worth a thousand
expert opinions and that has proven
itself time and again particularly the
world of physical testing if you're
getting on an airplane that somebody has
built are you willing to accept a 10
percent uncertainty on these numbers or
do you want it to be done certainty of
these measurements to be down in the mud
I think that's what you want tik-tok
[Music]
you